and then of course
the at the distributors the distributed
network
of humans that use these systems so like
you can have
the system itself then the neural
network but you can also have like
little algorithms controlling the
behavior of humans which is what you
have with social networks
it's possible that a very what is a
toaster whatever the opposite of skynet
when taken at scale was used by
individual humans and controlling their
behavior can actually
have the skynet effect yeah so this the
scale there we might have that now
we might have that now we just don't
know yeah like what has this happened
is twitter creating a little mini skynet
i mean because what happens it twirls
out
ramifications in the world and is it
really that much different if it's a
robot with tentacles or a bunch of
servers that
yeah and the destructive effects could
be
i mean it could be political but it
could also be like you know
you could probably make an interesting
case that the virus
the the coronavirus spread on twitter
too
in the minds of people like the fear and
the misinformation in some very
interesting ways
yeah mixed up and maybe this pandemic
wasn't sufficiently dangerous to where
that could have created a weird like
on instability but maybe other things
might create instability like somebody
god forbid detonates a nuclear weapon
somewhere and then maybe the destructive
aspect of that
would not as much be the military
actions
but the way those news are spread on
twitter yeah and the panic that creates
yeah yeah i mean i think that's a great
case study right like
what happened not but i'm not suggesting
that lexico let off the nuclear bomb i
meant the coronavirus but
okay but but yeah i think that's a
really interesting case study
um i'm interested in the counterfactual
of 1995.
like do the same virus in 1995. so first
of all it would have been
i get to hear whatever the nightly news
we'll talk about it and then there'll be
my local health
board we'll talk about it that
mitigation decisions would probably
necessarily be very
sort of localized like our community is
trying to figure out what are we going
to do what's going to happen like we see
this with schools like
where i grew up in new jersey there's
very localized
school districts so even though they had
sort of
really bad viral numbers there my school
i grew up in has been open since the
fall because it's
very localized it's like these teachers
and these parents what do we want to do
what are we comfortable with
i live in a school district right now in
montgomery county that's a billion
dollar a year budget 150 000 kid
school district it just can't it's
closed you know because it's too
so i'm interested in that counterfactual
yes you have all this information moving
around
and then you have the the the effects on
discourse that we were talking about
earlier that
the the neil postman style effects of
twitter which shifts people into a sort
of a dunk culture mindset of
don't give an inch to the other team and
we're used to this and was fired up by
politics and the unique attributes of
twitter
now throw in the coronavirus and
suddenly we see decades of public health
knowledge a lot of which was honed
during the hiv epidemic
was thrown out the window because a lot
of this was happening on twitter
and suddenly we had public health
officials using a don't give an
inch to the other team mindset of like
well if we say this
that might validate something that was
wrong over here and we need to if we say
this then maybe
like that'll stop them from doing this
that's like very twittery
yeah in a way that in 1995 is probably
not the way
public health officials would be
thinking or now it's like well
this is if we said this about mass but
the other team said that about mask we
can't give an inch
so we got to be careful and like we
can't tell people it's okay after
they're vaccinated because that might
we're giving them an inch on this and
that's very twittery in my mind right
that is the the impact of
twitter on the way we think about this
course which is a dunking culture of
don't give any inch to the other team
and it's all about slam dunks where
you're completely right and they're
completely wrong
it's as a rhetorical strategy it's
incredibly simplistic but it's also the
way that we think right now about
how we do debate it combined terribly
with a
election year pandemic yeah election
year pandemic i wonder if we could do
some smooth analysis let's run the
simulation over a few times
a little bit noise yeah see if it can
dramatically change the behavior of the
system
you